notre dame de chartres et notre dame de
paris
ces deux joyaux de l'art gothique
partage désormais un drame similaire
qu'arrangeur 1836 un incendie a embrasé
la charpente de la cathédrale de
chartres en rénovation comme le montre
ce tableau est la ressemblance est
troublante à chartres c'était bien
effectivement des soudeurs en réparation
sur le toit
qui avait été imprudent en fin de
journée avec un feu qui avait pris sur
la partie médiane de la cathédrale à ses
proches de la croisée du transept et
qui a embrasé l'ensemble de la charpente
de la forêt comme on dit en quelques
heures
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui la france
était sous le choc les politiques
appelaient dès le lendemain à la
reconstruction de la cathédrale
après deux ans de réflexion c'est la
proposition la plus moderne qui est
choisie celle d'une toiture en cuivre
aujourd'hui vert de gris et d'une
charpente en forme de faire une
structure métallique qui présentait deux
avantages
donc cessons le fait qu'elle me soir un
combustible
ce qui fait que chartres tank est
désormais à l'abri d'un grand incendie
camp
voir sur notre dame et aussi une
structure beaucoup plus légère que la
structure de bois précédente
et c'était sans doute une précaution
utile étant donné les gradations qui
avaient eu lieu pendant grâce à ce choix
à la charpente a pu être achevée dès
1841 d'après l'architecte des bâtiments
de france il existe de très nombreux
documents sur la reconstruction de la
charpente de la cathédrale de chartres
de 1836 à 1841 des débats des analyses
des deux vies bref toute une
documentation qui pourrait aider à
apporter des pistes de réflexion et à
rebâtir la charpente de notre dame de
paris